Speaker 1: Republicans are now bragging about
diversity. Quite literally in a room full of
white people, mostly white men. This you just have
to see it. And I want to talk about diversity in
sort of a more serious way and actually take the
question of diversity more seriously. Republicans
have started to repeat lines like this is one
of the most diverse Republican classes we've
ever had. We have more women, we have more this
that. The other thing they thought they had more
Jewish people because they were including George
Santos in that. Turns out that that was a lie. And
during the event that they did yesterday
with Fox News propagandist Sean HANNITY,
they talked about this issue of diversity a couple
of times. I'm going to play a couple of clips for
you. Here is Sean HANNITY saying he loves seeing
more diversity in the Republican Party. You know.
Speaker 2: Congressman, I know
I've known you a long time.
One of the things I'd like to see and I'm seeing
is more diversity in the Republican Party. To me,
the Democratic Party is the party of coastal.
Speaker 1: Okay. I think it's the elites,
coastal elites. Yes. And then Elise
Stefanik actually talks about it and
she does some of the types of
bragging we've heard for the
last few weeks from Republicans.
Speaker 3: Take a look around at
these wonderful members. This is the most
diverse class of Republicans ever elected
in the history of the United States Congress. We
have more women that were ever elected before,
more Hispanic members ever elected before.
Speaker 1: Now, as you see the camera panning,
it's basically all white men in the room for
this very special Republican event. I guess I see
three women in the background. Someone pointed
out that there's one guy that maybe is Hispanic,
but okay, you get the point.
Speaker 3: More African-American
members in modern history. This shows that
our party is growing. And I will tell you,
the America First agenda is a growing big tent
agenda. We've never done better than we do today
among Hispanic voters. And President Trump and
House Republicans were a huge part of doing that.
Speaker 1: Okay. So there's a few things
that we have to understand. First of all,
when the initial when they talk about we're doing
better than ever with a lot of these groups, when
you start with such disastrous numbers, you really
only have up as the direction that you can go. So
I wouldn't read too much into that. But what these
Republicans very much expose is that for them,
this issue of diversity is checking a box. It's
perfunctory, it's contrived, it's just something
that they can say so that they can argue, hey, we
also have different types of people here like the
Democrats do. It's not organic. It doesn't stem
from policy. It comes from who can we fleece?
Because the entire movement is a scam. We expose
that two weeks ago. You can check out the segment
Modern Modern conservatism is a scam. But the
reality is that these aren't just boxes that you
check. The makeup of political constituencies is a
direct reflection of the policies or the perceived
policies of those groups. And that's why this
can very quickly become a fraught debate. First
of all, it's not about we need the exact makeup in
our elected officials of the population at large.
You can never really achieve that because you
can always say, Hey, you know what? There's the
population is 50.3% women, so we should have
50.3% women in the House of Representatives.
Okay. All right. Well, you probably do that.
Okay. Here's the racial demographics of the
country. They should be exactly represented in the
House of Representatives. Okay. Maybe you could
do that. All right. Here's the percentage of the
country that is immigrants that should be exactly
represented. Also, the percentage of people
with a physical disability should be. But sexual
orientation, it's extraordinarily difficult to
have a perfect mirroring in our elected officials
of every demographic alignment in the general
population. That's not what this is about. I
don't believe that's what the left is actually
talking about. The important thing to know
is that voter demographics that support political
groups vary based on a lot of different factors.
It can depend on the candidates that are that are
running and how they appeal to different groups of
people. It could depend on what the most important
issues are when national security and the economy
maybe are the issues being emphasized. You're
going to see a different demographic alignment
than if the issues are, say, abortion and
education just for picking certain ones. But
what we see is that overwhelmingly there is very
little diversity in the Republican Party. Now,
I know Trump does these events and he puts blacks
for Trump on the stage behind him. And it's all
very stage managed, for lack of a better term.
But roughly speaking, somewhere between 89 and
93% of black voters vote for Democrats, 93% voted
for Joe Biden. Based on exit polls, 78% of LGBT
voters voted for Biden. 71% of Jewish-Americans
identify as or lean towards Democratic candidates.
66% of Hispanic or Latino voters voted for Biden.
66% of Asian American voters voted for Biden,
62% of naturalized citizens. People like me
voted for Joe Biden. 60% of those 18 to 29
voted for Joe Biden. 59% of disabled voters
voted for Joe Biden, 55% of women. Okay,
you're getting closer and closer to 5050.
Diversity isn't something you do to get it on
record. Ready? Go. Hey, we got some Jewish folks
like Jorge Santos. Oh, he's not Jewish. All right,
cross him off the list. But we've still got
more Latino voters than we've had before.
It's a reflection of policy. It's a reflection of
policy. The way the Republican Party goes about
it is let's just see if we can find people
who check certain boxes and convince them to
vote for us rather than let's develop a policy
platform that will naturally attract different
groups of voters. They're sort of going like top
down rather than building from the bottom up.
And it's not clear whether that will work as a
long term political strategy. Their numbers have
improved slightly over the last couple of election
cycles with some of these groups, but with others,
they continue to be a disaster. The way the
Republican Party sees this issue is just like
a product. What kind of a product can we build
by adding people who check different demographic
boxes and as a result, they're really not doing
well with just about any of these groups. The
irony, of course, is as the room pans, the camera
pans, it's all white people and mostly white men,
which is really in contrast to the words about
diversity that are coming out of their mouths.